The United States
Coast Guard is tracking a suspected
Russian spy ship
that has been spotted
in international waters off
the coast of Hawaii.
This as tensions
between Washington and Moscow ov
Russia's war in Ukraine are Ever
CNN's Oren
Liebermann is live at the Pentag
And what is the Pentagon
saying this morning about this s
so close,
given it's off the coast of Hawa
Caitlin, it's the Coast Guard
that's been tracking this ship
for the course of the past sever
And as you point out,
what's interesting here is the t
all the tension between the U.S.
and Russia,
between Washington and Moscow.
The Coast Guard says
they've been tracking the ship
for several weeks now
and believe
that it is
a Russian intelligence
gathering ship in plain language
a spy ship
that's been hanging out
in international waters
off the coast of Hawaii.
Coast Guard has been monitoring
with the help of the Defense Dep
It's not illegal or in any way u
for Russian intelligence
gathering ships
or frankly,
other ships and other aircraft
to be in international waters
or international airspace,
gathering intelligence, essentia
picking up what they can
in international waters.
It's the timing here
that makes this interesting.
And according to the Coast Guard
the length of the time
they've been watching this
right off the coast of Hawaii.
Caitlin
And so how long is it, you know,
if it is common
for something like this to happe
But we were seeing it
get this close before,
especially in the last year and
when we've seen these tensions
at an all time high between
Russia and the United States,
perhaps not
in the last year and a half,
but we have seen Russia
acting like this in the past.
For example, just a couple of ye
there was a Russian spy ship
off the east coast of the US
off of Florida.
What made that one different is,
operating international waters.
But DOD called it out
and operating in an unsafe manne
meaning operating without runnin
and not responding to commercial
That's where these become incide
and perhaps were even raised
at the diplomatic level.
Another example on the flip side
just a few weeks ago, we saw a U
reconnaissance aircraft
intercepted by Chinese aircraft
in international airspace.
Again, that's key here.
What made that different is the
accused China
of acting in an unsafe manner
and getting too close to the U.S
aircraft.
That's when these rise
above simple interactions
and become incidents
that can have consequences
and are raised at diplomatic lev